man don't tell the man stats we
know he's a bad free-throw shooter
gives it up jokic and he's met by green
nice block by danny green howard was
there as well
and howard got a piece of that man
before second claw
this is what i mean dwight howard
not as athletic as he once was but still
more athletic
than most big man in the league and
laterally he can move
and when he's defending and not fouling
like on that possession
so valuable on both ends of the floor
just think how many fouls
howard mcgee can give if you end up
you're gonna go small anyway if you're
the lakers with a d at the five in a
close game
that's going to put a lot of body work
on jokic harris runs into a wall in
dwight now a bad pass
another turnover here comes caruso he's
got lebron james right there
the love to lebron
and if you're michael malone you cannot
be happy
with the turnovers dwight howard in the
middle of the
nuggets camp there creating a little
scene this is the veteran presence
that you have on this laker team and you
just love it
this is great huddle what does that mean
it's a good lip reading too there chris
way to clean it up
because chris has been there into the
hands of caruso
second chance opportunity here for la
leave and kcp with a finish line series
he's come back strong
he's been a big factor here for la nice
lead for kcp
in the lakers but to be fair you could
have put that resume up of lebron james
versus about 25-26 teams
and it would have been the same thing oh
nice leave
anthony davis on the receiving end once
again
and the smart pass right there all you
have to do is raise your eyebrows make
eye contact with your point guard game
reggie didn't get his feelings hurt
there we didn't give him the assist
package
but there will be
12 assists on the 15 makes as c webb
mentioned
lakers out in front by four and marquee
morris hits a three-pointer well on cue
or top has been a very effective group
for the lakers up top howard throws it
down
what 11 fast break points make that 13
for the lakers in here
a little bit of payback throwing it up
jokic coming off a 13
assist game and a triple double against
the clippers in game seven
rondo goes right by porter and finishes
with the left hand
two of seven five points we talked about
michael porter junior the third
scorer the lobs are everywhere reg
[Applause]
well that was special right there and
now rondo forcing that turnover here
goes caruso out of the pack
gives it up rondo bounce pass dave is
patient
well that was special right there and
now rondo forcing that turnover here
goes caruso out of the pack
gives it up rondo bounce pass dave is
patient
and a two-handed jam no davis
good find that time on a bounce pass
six four six five could play either
guard position
excellent defender rondo open for three
oh he's having a night
rondo turning the corner a little
floater up and over the backboard
oh man you're right this is some pistol
pete larry bird behind the backboard
come on oh that's beautiful that's
beautiful great camera work right there
rondo there's another bounce pass to
davis and he'll finish
good catch by davis that's the second
overhead bounce pass that rondo has
delivered in this game
davis he's got jeremy grant on him he'll
just pull it
knock it down 37 for anthony davis so
easy